اسرائيل التزمت الصمت لم تنفي ولم تتبنى
لانها ارادت اولا ان تبقي الباب مفتوحا
على احتمال ان توجه اصابع الاتهام ايضا
باغتيال الشيخ العاروري الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التي كانت في عام
2015 قد اعلنت عنه ووصفته بانه ارهابي
دولي وفي عام
2018 اعلنت عن مكافاه قيمتها 5 ملايين
دولار لمن ياتي بمعلومات تقود للق ض عليه
لذلك اسرائيل ابقت الباب مفتوحا ثانيا
اسرائيل ارادت ترى بان اغتيال الشيخ صالح
العاروري قد ادخل حزب الله وامينه العام
نصر الله في ورطه من ناحيه ان العاروري
كان ضيفا لديهم ولم تتم حمايته كما يجب
وقتل في الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت الخاضعه
لحزب الله وهذا يضع ح نصر الله وحزب الله
حسب سب اسرائيل امام خيارين اما ان يرضخ
للمجهود الدبلوماسي المبذول وينهي حرب
الاستنزاف التي اصطاد اسرائيل فيها منذ
بدايه الحرب على غزه او ان تتفجر حرب
شامله كما تدعو بعض اطراف الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اما السبب الثالث في هذا
الشان فهو ان نتنياهو اراد التريث حاليا
لانه يريد استثمار ذلك ايضا في خدمه
مكاسبه السياسيه الحزبيه هم يرودون يرون
بان اغتيال العاروري هو صيد ثمين جدا
العاروري كان على راس قائمه قاده حماس
الذين كانت اسرائيل تعلن انها ستستهدف
وتبدا بعمليات اغتيالهم ومنذ بدايه هذه
الحرب التي دخلت يومها
ال9 قامت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بمداهمات منزله الخالي منذ نحو 20 يوم
عاما في بلده منذ اكثر من 20 عاما في بلده
عاره مسقط راسه الشمالي لمدينه رام الله
وحولته في خطوه انتقاميه الى مركز للشباك
اجرت فيه تحقيقات مع عشرات من المواطنين
الفلسطينيين هناك ثم قامت بتدميره وهو في
خطوه انتقاميه كانت موجهه ضمن رساله له
وهي تعتبره ايضا بانه على جانب كبير من
الخطوره كونه كان احد ثلاثه كما تقول
علموا بسر وبمختلف
الاقصى في السابع من اكتوبر الماضي وكما
انه كان من مؤسسي الذراع العسكريه لحماس
كتائب القسام ومسؤول عن توجيه العديد من
الهجمات التي استهدفت اسرائيل و وجيشها في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه لذلك هي حتى الان لم
تعلن لانها تتريث ولكن في نفس الوقت اعلنت
عن جهوزيه كامله لقواتها على طول الحدود
مع لبنان ودعمت ذلك وعززت ايضا بمزيد من
منظومات القبه العم حديديه والبيوت تحسبا
من ان ينفجر الوضع على نطاق واسع جدا